I hope to get a hundred percent because
I love doing well in school because I
was raised in an environment which
valued learning me too yeah privileged
so bad
privilege is a very loaded term in a
word is access an advantage that you're
either born with or that was handed to
you and he has a lot to do with how your
identity benefits from a system that has
been in place for a very very long time
yeah winning the birth lottery to put it
bluntly
I have no idea to each other I'm white
but I'm also Native American I'm a man
but I'm also gay I'm a Christian but I'm
also poor I'm probably gonna rank pretty
low as a person of color as a woman I am
a straight white guy went to an Ivy
League school those parents have
graduate degrees and you wear polo tees
I feel super privileged and I don't know
how to talk about it which is why I'm
forcing myself to be in this video being
a person who of intersectional
identities if it's not the Asian side of
me it's the female side of me or the
queer side of me I'm a middle class
white person I expect to be very
privileged I don't think I'll be
surprised at where I land or what you
see is not necessarily what you get with
me I think I'd probably be in like the
middle upper maybe in the middle as a
woman of trans experience and as a woman
of Asian American background like 5050
I'm excited to play the oppression
Olympics and see what medal I get USA do
you think Donald Trump got like a
thousand percent on this whoo this is
complicated I am a man because obviously
identify as a man but a man of trans
experience I have never been
discriminated against because of my skin
color I think I have to check this I
have never been mocked for my accent my
family has Southern roots and I grew up
really poor so I definitely didn't grow
up speaking the way that I'm speaking
now I am NOT nervous and airport
security always nervous I've been pulled
aside before where they're like um we
see something in like this pointing to
the junk area see I've never even
thought about the way trans people
experience airport security oh yeah I
have lied about my sexuality I have had
to come out and I have doubted my
parents acceptance of my sexuality so I
have not had to do that
I have never pretended to be just
friends with my significant other I have
that one just got me having dated women
and also having been in interracial
relationships with men I've definitely
had those moments I have lied about my
religion I guess I feel like I need to
take a shower I've never been told I am
attractive for my race does that happen
yeah I have never felt unsafe because of
my gender I have never been catcalled
I've never been sexually harassed or
assaulted not
checking any of those never been called
a [ __ ] I actually have this crush is a
slap in the face my family and I've
never lived below the poverty line Hades
rub it in I don't know how I expected
this to go but us a lot of check marks I
have worked as a waiter barista
bartender or salesperson in fact have
worked all four of those jobs I was a
barista I work at my aunt's restaurant
for a one weekend I have never attempted
suicide I've never been depressed like
all that just kind of hits a little too
close to home
not having student loans is the thing I
feel luckiest about my life thanks mom
and dad
I do not rely on public transportation
see you don't think about public
transportation when you think about
privilege I knew that I was privileged
but this survey is making me think of a
lot of things that I don't actually
think about on a daily basis I've never
lied about my ethnicity of self-defense
I absolutely have and I get away with it
because I'm biracial I consider myself
to be physically attractive is that
something that like is easy to check I
checked that easily really yeah I didn't
check it really I consider myself to be
physically attracted yeah I've never
been violently threatened for my
religious beliefs I never have and I
immediately made me like why no crack
because it's like as I speak this
sentence that's happening to people I
was not bully as a child for any of my
identities I mean yes I was what is
smaller Oh does anyone have some joints
for after this because like we're good
pillow that I could hold it and cry
I feel a little sad
all of a sudden um because there was
just so many things I couldn't check I
came into this thinking that I was
pretty privileged and I left feeling
even more privileged recognizing your
own privilege is definitely a step in
the right direction every day I'm
obviously very inundated with the fact
that I don't have a whole lot of
privileges but I think that I often
forget the ones that I do benefit from
it's worth it to look into learning
about the privilege that you have
because it lets you use it better to
like better the lives of the people
around you I encourage everyone to take
a look at their own privilege even if
you consider yourself to be someone who
is at a disadvantage you're probably
more privileged than someone else going
into this test the advice that I would
give is to know that it's not going to
define who you are it's not going to
define your character and it's not going
to define your space in life those are
things that you can create on your own
outside of privileges it just depends on
how you create a path to get there
Wow